- One of my favorite moments
from the whole thing,
was when she just flat out asked you,
because you had said, "One
of the gutsiest things,"
she'd asked you a
question, you said, "Hey,
"one of the gutsiest
things I've ever done"
was staying in your marriage
when no one expected you to.
- Yeah.
I used to be a very private person.
That all ended when,
(audience laughing mildly)
I ended up in public life.
- Yeah-
- And,
I know, because-
- So fun!
- I know, because I've now,
(Kelly laughing)
you know, lived a long time.
Everybody goes through something.
I mean relationships
which are at the core,
of who you are and how you define,
the meaning in your life,
everybody goes through something.
And not everybody, like you
or me, does it in public.
But everybody goes through it.
And so if we can,
and you've done such a important service
in being open and
talking, and sharing that.
And so, for me to be able to say,
"Look, everybody has to make
the decision that's best
"for her or him, and it's not
gonna be the same decision."
- 'Cause we're all different-
- We're all different.
- And nobody knows the whole relationship-
- Nobody-
- In the scope of your life.
- Knows-
- Yeah.
- And we need to respect that,
if it's a responsible decision.
I mean, you know,
I know people who, you know,
they can't make a decision
because they're still not
clear in their own heads
how to best manage what
they are in right now,
and how to get out of it
or how to, make it better.
But, you gotta go through the process.
You can't short-circuit the process.
- Yeah.
- And so when you say,
"Yeah, you've been going
through it," you do.
And you know, for me, it took
a lot of, thought and prayer,
and trusted friends and
confidants to talk to,
and really, think through out loud,
and I, you know, I made
the right decision for me.
I have no regrets.
And so I want everybody to feel that way.
And, that doesn't mean that it's perfect
'cause nothing in life is, but,
you do the best you
can and then you go on.
And that's what we should be looking to.